[Music]
thank you for joining us we're glad
you're here you know there's two things
when I talk about investing to people
that they say
they say well nobody can beat the market
I'm just gonna invest in index funds I
read a book and I read an article on the
internet now everything on the internet
is true Abraham Lincoln said that think
about it it'll come to you later the
other is is that people say well you
can't beat the market and investing is
too complicated
I mean investing is intimidating
investment people are intimidating
I feel 2 inches tall when I talk about
investing it's intimidating well the
second one is true it is intimidating
but it shouldn't be it's really not that
complicated and when you sit down with
someone that actually knows what the
flip they're doing they can help you put
the cookies on the Shelf where you can
reach them that's called a teacher and
you don't understand about mutual funds
and you understand about the track
record on a mutual fund and that's how I
started investing many years ago now I
know there's a lot of people that have
opinions about my investment advice but
I do have millions of millions of
dollars in mutual funds I wonder how
that got there
it must have been that I understood
something about that that money just
didn't appear there I haven't hit the
lottery I was bankrupt at 28 years old
I'm 57 so what happened during that
30-year period of time well I used the
investment principles that I talked
about here on the air I don't tell you
to do something and then go do something
different I do what I tell you to do oh
and by the way it worked for me and lots
of others lots of millionaires calling
in on the millionaire theme hours say
David I got out of that I loaded up my
401k with the four types of mutual funds
I loaded up my Roth IRA with
four types of mutual funds and Here I am
20 years later and I'm a millionaire
thank you and I get that all the time so
apparently the stuff we're teaching
works and it's not that complicated
and my mutual fund groupings have beat
the market you just pick mutual funds
that have outperformed the S&P it's
really not rocket science not all of
them have outperformed the S&P a lot of
them haven't
over half happened but don't pick one
that didn't you would be better to do
that but I mean you know it's like some
of you sitting at the racetrack and
you're gonna bet on horses I don't bet
on horses just because I don't know
anything about it and I don't gamble
because I don't like losing money I work
too hard for it so but if you're sitting
I went to a dog track one time or a
horse track one time when I was a
youngster and they tell ya you know this
horse has not won a race ever
so bet on that one stupid you know this
horse won the last three races oh I
probably might bet on him you know
that's all you're doing when you're
picking a mutual fund did it beat the
market if it didn't beat the market then
don't pick that mutual fund that's not
rocket science that horse hadn't won a
race don't bet on that horse why is this
hard it's not hard and this idea that
you have to do what's called passive
investing and surrender and say oh well
you really can't beat the S&P Dave
Ramsey doesn't know what he's talking
about no I mean I pulled up my stuff the
other day and looked at it let's see
anything I got written down here just
because I don't have it all memorize
this here oh the mutual funds I'm
personally invested in the four types I
talked about over the last 40 years I've
averaged 13.4% you can't get 12% on your
money
I I know I got 13 okay and the S&P
during that time averaged eleven point
eight one percent which is real close to
twelve stupid people thirty-year my
investments of average eleven point
three the S&P is averaged ten point
eight nine so outperform the S&P on the
30 on the 40 outperform the S&P on the
20 on the 10-year outperform the S&P huh
go figure so how did I do that I pick
four mutual funds that outperformed the
S&P I pick horses that win the race I
mean what you look down to the track
record and it's got a little chart in
there it's got the S&P one line and if
your mutual fund you're looking at lines
not above this Soompi line on the chart
you're looking at the wrong one pick you
another one why would you bet on a horse
I don't want to race this is really not
rocket surgery people I mean think about
it it'll come to you Wow so how you do
this well you sit down with somebody
knows what they're doing and they teach
you about mutual funds and that's how we
came up with a whole smart Buster Pro
idea we put that in place to help people
that don't have a lot of money and don't
know anything about it and are
intimidated but then along comes the
internet and lies to you and you can't
do that oh really
okay maybe you can't but I can and I
have and it's resulted in millions and
millions and millions of dollars
lots of millions by the way it's worked
out good I'm having a good time yo life
is good
so if you're ready to do this you want
to sit down with someone to look at your
financial picture and help you do your
investing you're at baby step four
you're ready to get started you want to
be a millionaire you want to live like
no one else so later you can live and
give like no one else so you can retire
with dignity and not have to buy that
cookbook 72 ways to prepare Alpo and
love it you know people that rich hire
wealthy it wasn't an accident
they didn't get to wealth you get to
retirement go how that happened where
did that come from they're not surprised
they know exactly where that money came
from it was an intentional act
year after year month after month
paycheck after paycheck being deducted
into their 401k into the Roth IRA into
good mutual funds year after year after
year after year after year after year
it's just not sexy it's not a fish story
to tell on the golf course it's just the
tortoise he just keeps walking
he's ugly just keeps walking he's ugly
and nobody notices him but that's how
you become a millionaire what all the
data points tell us so the other Dave
Ramsey comm click on smart investor I'm
not in the investing business I don't
give a rip if you invest or not I'm here
to teach you but I am getting little
spit sick and tired of the trolls out
there bumping around the internet
talking about how stupid Dave Ramsey's
investment advice is when my net worth
is tens of millions of dollars so I must
be doing something right other than just
selling books yeah I sold a lot of books
that's where some of that came from for
sure but most of it came from investing
you guys in real estate that I paid cash
for and in good mutual funds see if you
put money in at the bottom of the market
when the market was what sixty nine
hundred sixty four hundred whatever it
was at the bottom but for the crash the
big crash of 2008 do you remember when
the world came to an end if you put
money in there and what's the Dow today
twenty four thousand what is six
thousand to twenty four thousand is that
four times you think you guys that are
quick with your second grade math is
that four times so if you put in a
million dollars at the bottom what would
you have now four million dollars uh
this is not hard but the stock market
they see you've got to learn people
you've got to learn what's really going
on out there in the real estate world
and in the investing world if you want
to have any money the CD is not going to
get you there it's a certificate of
depression it's paying less than 1% in
most cases
if you got a really good one it's one
and a half zippy
so click smart Wester at Dave Ramsey
comm put in your information it'll drop
down a list of the smart mister pros the
people we recommend in your area they'll
sit down with the heart of a teacher and
calmly show you mutual funds that
outperform the market and they'll
uncomplicate the supposedly complicated
process where you understand it and when
you understand it that only then do you
know you're investing don't do it
because I said so only then this is the
Dave Ramsey chef